hello everyone and welcome to round one
of the 2018 London chess classic it's
the final event of the 2018 segrand
chest or and in round one we have a
Fabiano Corwin / Sakura Nakamura and on
the other table eleven are unknown faced
off against Maxine bar Sherlock Rob but
this is the game that were interested in
as it's a it's Fabiano's chance to
overtake crossing as world number one in
live ratings and also it's very
interesting this is a Fabriano first
game after efforts classical game after
the worcester championship match against
magnus carlsen and during this game i
think he's not a hundred points higher
rated than Hikaru but I don't think it's
far from that I think some 85 points so
there's a lot of pressure on on Fabiano
here and the other hand there's not a
lot of pressure on he car oh here he
doesn't really have anything to prove
here of course he would like to prove
himself against his fellow countryman
but other than that he can only spoil
Bobby's attempt to overtake caution as
the world's number one it's a it's a
very exciting game and none of them pull
any punches back it's well just a crazy
one so I do hope you enjoy it
the entire prize fund for the one that
just classic 2018 is three hundred
thousand dollars where the first prize
is one hundred and twenty thousand
dollars so a lot of money for this event
and of course everyone who wants to win
it but okay as far we said he doesn't
really care about the money anymore he
just wants to you know get gets the
results and get that first place so
let's check it out Fabi has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 c4 e6 and now Knight to f3
and d5 of course we transpose into the
Queens gambit declined the the games are
played in the deep mind Google
headquarters in London if but they are
always played there for long just
classic so as far as I know so I don't
know if I mentioned that last year I was
covering the games market nice to see
three the three nights line of the the
Queens gambit declined with a push up to
e7 Bishop to f4 and now castles this is
all still Sanders
of the Queens gambit declined III we
have b6 Hikaru prepares the Finca to the
light square Bishop Queen to c2 and now
comes Bishop to b7 s planned rook to d1
Bishop to d6 challenging the bishop on
f4 and now Bishop the g3 and here you
could capture but as the old saying goes
you know to take is a mistake you don't
really gain anything you just give white
a semi-open h-file and well this is
playable there's there's really no
reason to do this yes you have you have
messed up White's pawn structure on the
Kings side but you know what a semi-open
h-file white doesn't really care he's
not gonna Castle there he's gonna just
play Bishop to d3 put the King on f1 and
the king will be perfectly safe there so
after Bishop to g3 Knight B to d7 here
I've heard he Cara mentioned in an
interview he wasn't sure about this idea
but he somewhat recalls that he saw it
somewhere right okay C capture Sun d5 we
have Knight captures on d5 and now II
for five before forces a lot of
exchanges to create a powerful Center
Knight captures on c3 be captures on c3
and now comes the bushel captures on g3
we have h captures and g3 and now II
five this is the idea how he Caro
conjures this very strong Center and
Bishop to b5 by Fabi you don't want to
capture here if you capture the pawn is
protected but after Queen to e7 after
the Queen attacks it you're just gonna
win it
let's say Bishop to c4 captures captures
captures and now black is perfectly fine
it has a very strong bishop on b7 and
after the rooks are developed black will
have perhaps an even even better
position but but okay
the the semi-open h-file will always be
dangerous so after a 5 we have Bishop to
b5 now c6 provoking this well maybe not
a weakness but for now this Bishop will
not be so strong so Bishop back to e2 by
Fabi and now comes Queen to c7 here he
car says he was considering either Queen
to c7 or Queen to e7 but he didn't like
Queen to e7
because this night could come to h5 h4
and then to f5 and you don't
when a weakened your position further by
playing g6 so perhaps the the Queen
would have been would be better on c7
and here Hikaru said that he
nevertheless even though he played the
Queen to c7 that he was expecting night
to h4 and that he was even afraid of
this if he plays it but Bobby didn't
play it still you would have to go back
Knight of 6 and then after the night
finds this very nice outpost on f5 if
you don't want to weaken your structure
you would have to go back with the
bishop and challenge the Knights this
way but ok Bobby found a different idea
at g4 and he carves said that he was
actually very happy to see this move
rook F de 8 Hikaru develops and even g5
now rook a to d8 so he Fabi grabbed some
space on the Kings side by playing this
g4 g5 idea but he car managed to develop
his his rooks in that time King to f1
like we said fob is no longer interested
in castling either king will be
perfectly safe on f1 and the rook will
be able to use the semi-open h-file b5
and now comes rope to h4 a very nice
move if g3 can be played maybe King g2
then this rook can come from d1 to h1
and then Bobby can already start a very
nice King side attack we have a 6 by
Nakamura and now comes a 4 and it's an
isolated a pawn you wanna trade at some
point for for blacks b-pawn now we have
Queen to a5 challenging day for pawn and
now comes a move very nice it really
really jump-starts the game here fab
played g6 something I always enjoy you
know it doesn't matter if if you can if
you can give up upon to make ur attack
happen just a little bit faster I always
I always think if you do it unless
you're like completely missing something
but here it actually works nicely we
have g6 and now you have to capture it
you don't want to allow pawn captures or
rook captures it would be just
devastating so H captures on g6 and now
comes nice to g5 and here you can
already sense what fob is going for the
night is has a very nice outpost on g5
the rook is on h4 and the plan
is putting this rook to d3 and bringing
it over to h3 so this work can of course
deliver checkmate on h8 and there is a
very nice way Nakamura can prevent this
but it's not it's not all that clear the
best move here to prevent this plan rook
to the 3 to h3 is actually C 5 C 5
because it opens up the attack from the
bishop to the e4 pawn and now if you
insist in this idea rook to d3
okay now Knight is defending d4 pawn but
now you play f6 and there are no tricks
with something like rook to h3 to give
up the night because you no longer
control the f7 square this check now
King escapes King f7 so after this c5
move if you insist on this roof to d3
then f6 you have to move the knight and
then comes a g5 kicking the rook back we
have roof to g4 and now e captures on d4
pawn captures and now after Bishop
captures here black will just win the
game as he wins the exchange so after
Knight to g5 he Karl didn't find this c5
idea but rather he played night to f8
and this is not very dangerous he allows
Fabi to go for his plan rook to d3 is
played and now the only way to actually
prevent rock to h3 is Bishop to ca not
allowing the rook to even come to h3
Queen to b3 now with an attack against
the b7 pawn against the f7 pawn and here
if you block it with if you block it
with the bishop then the knight will
capture it you will no longer be able to
defend the h3 square and if you go with
the knight then you can go rook to h3
immediately and again the bishop is no
longer guarding the night you cannot
capture of course this will be mate in
one market after Queen b3 Queen to c7
now the Queen is guarding the f7 pawn
and here we have a very exciting moment
where Bobby played a captures on b5
everyone thought that Knight captures on
f7 was the idea here with the plan that
after Queen captures rook to h8 check
King has nowhere to go King has the
capture and now you simply snatch the
Queen and f7 you win the Queen and the
game the problem with this idea is that
after you play this Knight captures on
f7
black will ignore you and simply play
Bishop to e6 with an attack against the
night and also against the Queen and
although you wouldn't blunder the game
here white can still force a draw here
you can't push for more than a draw you
have to go from Knight to g5 sacrifice
the Queen and then after the bishop
finally moves from protecting the h3
square you can go rook d to h3 and now
the defend against the disrupt a
checkmate first the black has to give up
a night and then after rook captures you
have to start running away with the team
came to f8 and now you get rook f3 check
and here you have to go back to GA if
you go you have to go the to g8 and
allow this perpetual again rook here
came here rook f3 checking goes back if
you don't do this if you instead try to
if after captures and the king to a fade
rook the three you decide to go to d6
and run away then then white will will
have to look after sin g7 because King
moves now rook checks roadblocks
captures captures and now even captures
on e5 King captures and now even f4
check captures Knight captures with
check Forks the king and queen king
captors and now white his job just up
too much material and of course winning
but like we said white will not be able
to the game more than a draw if he
insists on night capers on f7 so it
captures on b5 and okay we have a
capture son b5 and now here again it was
a very very intense moment but not
Kimura Fabia was very low on the clock
he was I think around 6 minutes here and
he has to make 15 more moves to reach
time control perhaps the the most active
plan would have been g4 here blocked the
bishops a attack on the h3 square
prepare rook to h3 but again black will
black will probably go 96 now and now
after Knight captures pawn captures rook
to h3 black will have a a nice plan of
escaping here but still it would be it
would be very dangerous what could have
ideas of pushing c4 going Queen to f3 to
not allow the King to escape here it
doesn't seem that it would be all that
easy for black but okay Fabi goes for
rook to a3 immediately goes now with a
triple attack against the f7 pawn and
here Bishop to e6 Nakamura defends
everything and now if you go with the
idea of Knight captures then you get
Knight captures rook h2 Rock f2 h3
but now the King immediately starts
running away King to f8 now you try to
you try to provoke of course Queen to e7
to deliver checkmate but the black will
not be fooled Queen to d6 and now after
captures captures you can exchange
everything with row cap Rock h8 check
King moves captures captures and after
Luke h8 checking moves D captures and
now after rook here captures captures
the material on the world will be equal
but black's pawn structure is much
better here and black will be black will
be better here so if Abby sees that this
is not possible he has the keep on
playing actively d5 again a very very
nice active move with a pawn C capture
Sun d5 who have each chapter Sun d5 here
far we've had only 5 more minutes on the
clock to reach time control and that's
12 more moves and here comes rook
captures on d5 if you go Bishop captures
on d5 then the white will ignore you of
course rook is coming to h3 and now
white will win the game so rook captures
Sun d5 had to be played and now comes
Knight captures and on e6 by Fabi
another idea you could try is a rope to
h3 offered the rook here but then after
Bishop captures it white will capture
the rook on d5 but then the bishop goes
back simple is that
and then after Knight captures Knight
captures again black will have a very
nice position and the King will always
have an escape route even though he
doesn't need one no because there's
nothing doubled on the h-file but again
an interesting idea which have been
after this rook after some d5 again G
for are trying to go for this active
line but then again black will create an
escape route from the key for the king
and after rook after a ch3 immediately
start running away with the king and the
King can all go to e7 and e8 and so on
and feel very safe there so far we see
that this will not work and it requires
a lot of calculation and he does not
have any more time on the clock so night
captures on e6f captures on e6 and now
rook F 2 H 3 finally Fabi doubles and
the H file eliminates blacks light
square bishop and here it's again very
dangerous if an idea like c4 and queen
to f3 can be executed controlling the f7
square then again there will be no
preventing rope to h8 and here hikaru
planned it out perfectly and he pretty
much blitzed out to this efore move so
now such ideas are no longer possible d4
pawn controls DF 3 square and well white
can capture the pawn and there there's
really no better move here if you try if
you start with a checked you're not
really gaining anything and if you try
something like c4 c4 seems like a very
nice move for for example after pawn
captures Bishop captures do not have a
Queen and Bishop eyeing the King here
and now after the rook moves let's say
rook to d4 you can go look to HH check
King to f7 and now after roof to c3
Queen is going to e5 and still you don't
have any way of making progress here
even though the king is on f7 it seems
like it seems amazing that the black
king can survive this but there's no way
to continue the attack it's it's really
a great position and any checks will be
met with rook to e7 the point is
controlling your 3 everything is fine
for black here pretty pretty amazing but
ok after E for rook captures on e4 as
Nakamura gave up a pawn Fabi decided to
capture it there's nothing better here
rook to e8 now nakamura is planning to
activate the Queen between to c5 and
bringing the rook over to a3 the perhaps
create some threats against the isolated
c3 pawn g3 by Fabi making some room for
the King so the King can come to g2 and
now Queen to c5 here Fabi only had 2
minutes on the clock for his next 7
moves
rook to e3 the rook from e3 is now
giving further protection to the c3 pawn
and here fab is planning rook to h4 to
bring this rook all the way to b4 and
this is a very nice plan
that's Nakamura
should have spent some more time perhaps
stopping Nakamura played rook to a3
kicking away a fabi's queen we have
Queen to be 2 and here a lot more
immediately blitzed out Queen to d6 here
Nakamura had some 20-something minutes
on the clock
maybe 21 or 22 and the far we had less
than 2 minutes
but perhaps better than this was a g5
this was an idea
and here with only a minute and a half
on the clock it's hard to say if Fabi
was expecting this as he prepared rook
to h4 of course he checked g5 as it's
the only move that prevents rook to h4
but it would be very nice to see what he
came up with here with her would only a
minute and a half on the clock but as
we've already seen in the World Chess
Championship match against Magnus
Carlsen it doesn't matter how long how
long time Fabi is he really really does
have nerves of steel but yeah here after
g5 you you will have to find a different
plan but then c4 will be an idea and
after rook captures an e3 pawn cap for
some d5 brew rook back to c3 Queen
captures Queen captures Queen captures
pawn captures you could go for this
where you will be up upon but with a
shattered pawn structure and with an
idea like rook to h5 it doesn't seem
like like black could do anything even
with a move like g5 so it's hard to say
but what I mean and then half on the
clock who knows what what father would
come up with Queen to d6 now rook to h4
immediately by Fabi rook to a4 doesn't
Nakamura doesn't want to allow this rook
to come to be foreign the create threats
against the b5 pawn so he offers an
exchange rook to a4 look rook to e4 now
going after the e6 pawn and now Queen to
a3 Nakamura offers a trade we have
captures captures and now Bishop to g4
threatening the opponent ecigs with
check we have looked the c5 and now
comes and Bishop captures on e6 and
Knight captures honey 6 and now rook
captures on e6
so you can see now that the material on
the board is completely equal and it
will be very hard to push for anything
here rope captors on c3 was played rook
captures rook captures and now rook
captures on g6
so Hikaru has two isolated bones but one
of them is a passport will he be able to
use it it's hard to say before was
planed group to be six you have to put a
room behind a passport
b3 into G to King to f7 bringing the
King into the game at four and now
Nakamura forces matters with g5
sacrifices upon to completely ruin
White's pawn structure F captors and g5
rook the C to check bringing the pawn
all the way to be two we have King to f3
and now comes upon to be beat you it's
very hard since the White King does not
occupy the last rank you don't have any
ideas with check and then bringing the
this point to a queening square so came
to g4 now comes King to g7 and here we
had a repetition of moves run b7 check
in g6 Ruby 6 check King g7 Ruby 7 check
and now comes King to g6 so a very
interesting game a very attacking game
and the Fabi really spent all of his
time trying to win this game and
overtake Costigan as the world's number
one but it seems Nakamura would not have
it and also I don't know if since behind
it is almost 100 rating points
high-rated Nakamura does he lose points
here for a draw I actually think he does
because during the World Chess
Championship games all of the 12
classical games were drawn so there was
no change in classical rating after the
12 games the ratings were the same I
think Carson was 28 35 and 5 was 28 to
132 yeah it's a 3-point difference so
yeah I think Fabi actually lost some
points here but I will have to check so
no change here no change at the top it's
not really something that I myself am
very impressed with if Carson doesn't
play for some time now and Fabi
continues playing it's yeah I mean there
is a very high chance that Fabi will be
the new world number one but I kind of
don't think that now that Carson
retained his title that
he even really cares about this when he
starts playing he's gonna see if he
wants to do something about that or not
buddy who's to say what's what so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it a bit
of a different style then I know you'll
want to see more alpha0 games I've seen
your comments you'll want more elf a
more alpha and I will show you a couple
more alpha zero games but then we have
to you know go cold turkey and go back
to human chess at some point there's a
one more nice tournament coming then we
will also be having the world blitz and
Rapids in December and well at some
point I will also start the capablanca
saga so that's it for this video I would
like to thank David Walter William Gould
a one-match adjacent major and Sean
Flynn for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content with some more
alpha constants as it seems thank you
all and I'll see you soon